bonjour à tous apple pourrait rentrer
dans la course pour créer un casque de
réalité virtuelle qui serait également
un casque de réalité augmentée alors
vous allez voir c'est une nouvelle qui
en tout cas ça parle encore avec des
pincettes mais qui est très intéressante
et qui révèle vraiment ce que pourrait
être l'avenir d'apple et des différents
pour lui d' apple et on y va
pour l'instant apple ne s'est pas du
tout positionné sur le casque de réalité
augmentée de réalité virtuelle on voit
qu'à pas de marquer le fond samsung par
exemple regarder au chai s'habille chez
samsung j'ai ce produit magnifique alors
un pour en profiter vous avez un peu con
mais bon pour en profiter il faut mettre
ici un smartphone à loyat quelqu'un donc
forcément il vous faut un smartphone
samsung un casque qui est développé en
partenariat avec oculus oculus qui était
rachetée par facebook si vous ne le
saviez pas donc c'est un truc qui peut
tout pas mal mais le problème qu'on a là
dessus si vous voulez sur ces cas ce que
l'an passé le casque j'utilise avec le
s7 de ma compagne justine
ce que je reproche vraiment à ses
produits quand vous mettez un casque
dedans quand vous mettez vos smartphones
ou profiter dans le casque même les
casques à les acheter c'est ça que vous
avez quand même vachement de
pixellisation donc sur la sensation
parfaite d'immersion on n'y est pas
encore hélas justement c'est là où apple
pourrait frapper très fort qui
souhaiteraient a priori a priori
proposer un casque en 8k huit cas dans
chaque oeil pour l'instant les télés
sont pas encore en 8k
il ya effectivement des modèles qui
existent en 8k ne sont pas
commercialisés l'a4 captain à arriver
chez nous alors là un casque en 8k qui
pour arriver à l'horizon 2020 ça
pourrait juste énorme
à savoir que ce casque en 8k ne serait
pas connecté avec un câble à un
ordinateur comme on peut retrouver
certains autres produits on aurait pas
de smartphone là on aurait effectivement
un produit complètement indépendant avec
un écran intégré et qui se connecterait
une espèce d'unités centrales qui ne
serait pas un mac ne serait pas un
ordinateur mais une espèce d'une des
centrales
apple will connecterez vient réseaux bas
débit pour communiquer toutes les
informations ce serait vraiment très
intéressant ça permettrait d'avoir un
produit mixte enfin un produit avec de
la réalité virtuelle et la réalité
augmentée
on voit que la réalité augmentée apple
se positionne dessus ils ont déjà montré
notamment au travers des ipad vous avez
des applications de réalité augmentée
alors c'est des choses qui vont
développer de plus en plus dans les
temps à venir aussi bien pour les
professionnels que pour les particuliers
ont coûté divertissement ludique on voit
qu'il ya des boîtes comme ikea qui par
exemple dans leur application bien vous
mettez chez vous via votre ipad via
votre tablette n'importe quelle tablette
vous pouvez visualiser les meubles
positionner chez vous ça
vraiment bluffant c'est super
intéressant et pour le professionnel on
voit que ce soit notamment au travers du
casque microsoft all all ends les
professionnels peuvent travailler dans
les centrales nucléaires chercher chez
areva ils font ça pour l'entretien des
centrales nucléaires et travailler que
des casques microsoft violence
donc c'est vraiment très intéressant
parce qu'on se rend compte que cet outil
qui peut paraître un petit peu gadget
plus pour le côté un peu pour se marrer
comme moi très clairement là dessus on
voit qu'il a réel intérêt à double usage
ou les dix pros ou particuliers donc
c'est vraiment super intéressant et
c'est justement là dessus que va
travailler apple mais avec un produit
vraiment très haut de gamme
là où avec le casque microsoft au
lawrence vous avez que la réalité
augmentée la houlette les casques oculus
vous avez de la réalité virtuelle avec
ce cas ce que là vous pourriez avoir
quelque chose de mixte de la réalité
virtuelle et la réalité augmentée
ça c'est super intéressant donc c'est un
projet qui pourrait arriver d'ici 2020
alors 2020 ça peut paraître loin quand
on dit comme ça mais là déjà on est déjà
en 2018 2020 c'est dans deux ans ce
produit pourrait arriver mais c'est pas
dit qu'il arrive un jour si vous voulez
parce que déjà 2020 c'est vraiment très
proches toutes les phases de conception
de tests ensuite d'industrialisation et
ensuite de commercialisation on n'y est
pas encore mais en tout cas s'il arrive
il pourrait vraiment ouvrir de nouveaux
horizons parce que aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que la réalité virtuelle
notamment où la réalité augmentée c'est
quelque chose qui n'en est qu'à ses
balbutiements
on va pas encore très loin je ne connais
pas beaucoup de monde qu'il faut c'est
d'un casque de réalité virtuelle pas
beaucoup de monde
moi je les ai j'utilise quasiment pas
j'ai vraiment eu un grand coup avec la
ps4 pro de chez sony pour avoir le
casque de réalité virtuelle je sais pas
s'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
l'utilisent si vous jouez si vous avez
une ps4
est-ce que vous utilisez ce casque de
réalité virtuelle moi je l'essayé avant
même sa sortie j'ai trouvé génial mais à
côté de ça j'ai pas de ps4 et si je
l'avais est ce que j'aurai tout le temps
avec un casque sur la tête
je suis pas sûr donc on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui la réalité virtuelle à
ait augmenté c'est pas des choses qui
ont une place dans nos foyers
mais par contre quelque chose qui va se
développer c'est l'avenir je dirais pas
forcément que d'internet que du jeu mais
c'est vraiment l'avenir
c'est là dessus on en aura des vrais
sensation d'immersion on aura même des
films tournés en 360 des séries tourné
en 360 les jeux je vous en parlais et à
usage professionnel par exemple
pour l'agglo pour la téléconférence pour
du travail à distance pour pouvoir
travailler avec des gens à l'autre bout
du monde vous les aurez à côté de vous
comme ce qu'a présenté mark zuckerberg
avec les solutions sur lesquelles ils
travaillent deux avec oculus vous auriez
vos avatars et vous pourriez vraiment
interagir avec eux c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va ouvrir de nouveaux
horizons
aujourd'hui on en est vraiment qu'à la
préhistoire c'est des choses qui vont se
développer
et justement il ya un vrai intérêt
stratégique pour apple de ne pas louper
ce marché en 2007 qui sont positionnées
sur les smartphones avec l'iphone
aujourd'hui l'iphone c'est plus de 60%
du chiffre d'affaires global de la boîte
donc imaginer savait pas pris le virage
où est-ce qu'ils en seraient aujourd'hui
demain ils pourraient aller sur les
casques de réalité virtuelle et réalité
augmentée c'est un marché à ne pas
louper
dès le début donc pour l'instant on en
est qu'au début on voit à travers ces
infos ya une vraie volonté de la part
d'apple d'aller chercher les
technologies du futur que pourrait
peut-être en tout cas et j'y crois
vraiment la réalité augmentée et la
réalité virtuelle
alors il se pourrait aussi que ça ne
sorte jamais que ce ne soit qu'un projet
qui n'a jamais plus loin que l'état de
prototype mais je serais quand même
relativement s'en prit le nom du projet
chez apple serait le thé 288 sera plus
trouver un peu plus sexy comme non
toutes ces infos ont été révélés par le
site cnet en indice qui nous prend
effectivement cette chose de très
intéressant c'est que apple a racheté la
société spécialisée dans la réalité
virtuelle branagh l'année dernière pour
la somme modique de 30 millions de
dollars
à savoir aussi qu'un peu s'intéresse de
très près au cloud gaming et pourrait
venir dans l'univers du jeu vidéo qui
dit claude gaming dit forcément lunettes
de réalité virtuelle
alors le club des ming vous me direz ça
n'a pas forcément un lien direct avec la
réalité virtuelle peut être pas tout de
suite mais demain à l'avenir on jouera
directement encore plus connectés
imaginez si vous avez un casque avec de
l'anti ennuis cas très clairement vous
allez vous passer d'une télé à distance
si vous jouez des amis je veux bien mais
si vous jouez tout seul en immersion
complète avec ça ça serait juste
fabuleux pour convaincre c'est un marché
en pleine évolution envoyé facebook qui
a racheté oculus samsung qui travaille
en partenariat avec oculus pour ses
casques de réalité virtuelle vous à des
microsoft qui a travaillé avec htc avec
acer pour les casques de réalité
actuel ce qu'il appelle la réalité mixte
parce qu'ils ont aussi leur propre
casque au nolens toutes ces grandes
marques dont je vous parlais htc acer il
y en a plein qui ont des casques de
réalité virtuelle google a même sorti
son petit qu'arbore quelle espèce de
quitte en carton sur lequel vous pouvez
poser vos smartphones pour profiter de
la réalité virtuelle donc c'est que de
choses qui pour l'instant n'est pas
encore trop mûrs mais qui va arriver et
en tout cas on voit qu'apple a raison de
se positionner dessus dites moi ce que
vous en pensez est ce que ça pourrait
vous intéresser
est-ce que vous utilisez aujourd'hui la
réalité virtuelle la réalité augmentée
pourquoi pas au travers de tables l'aide
de différentes applications
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
pensez comme moi que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'avenir sur lequel on va
aller et qui va se développer de plus en
plus où est a contrario vous pensez que
c'est un gadget que ça ne va pas marcher
c'est un peu comme les lunettes
connecter les goûts glace ou alors les
snapshots spectacle qui ne marche pas du
tout et qui ne marcheront pas qui a
priori pour vous n'auront pas d'avenir
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire au pouvoir en discuter
ensemble comme d'habitude vous invite à
vous abonner parce que vous allez voir
qu'on va pareil toujours plus de teck ce
soit la réalité virtuelle de l'art est
augmentée des smartphones des produits
des robots dessine ça il ya plein de
choses qui arrivent
ça va être super cool comme d'hab
laissez-moi des jolies pouces je vous
dis à très bientôt soyez sages pour les
soirées vous d'ici là je vous embrasse
et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]